jamila
this
we see
some physical fisticuffs between titania
and she-hulk we see some legal
fisticuffs between titania and she-hulk
please tell me this is not the last we
see of her in this series it's not the
last dc of her in this series she's far
too annoying to go away
i gotta say one of my highlights of the
last few days was seeing titania at new
york fashion week
what was she doing there was she working
on collabs was she just trying to show
off what was the deal
titania took new york
you know i think that that was very it's
very fun that our show breaks the fourth
wall and i have continuously done that
since we started promoting like i
spray-painted titania across the
she-hulk posters in los angeles on
sunset boulevard i have decided to take
the fresh approach of method acting
after the role rather than before which
is weird and completely unhelpful but
extremely fun
it looks like you're having a blast on
yeah could you could you see titania
going up against uh any of the other
mcu heroes or teaming up with any any
other mtu villains absolutely and i mean
titania's got such a rich history
throughout marvel and she has so many
enemies i mean she's she's enemies of
spider-man with thor and even with the
man who eventually becomes her husband
the absorbing man so
i there are a plethora of people that
titania can fight and irritate and i
hope i get the chance to to play some of
those out now i didn't realize how
enterprising she was she's got a lot of
beauty products is there anything in her
line
that would have helped with that
uh
very particular
injury that you said that you sustained
uh while filming stunt work for the show
my god i'm so mad at myself for jokingly
telling that story on the red carpet
it's haunted me ever since
um
no i don't think that there is anything
that titania sells
that's
for the butthole
but i wouldn't put it past her to invent
one okay so just watch that space
that's about that space the other space
the titanium space
keep your eyes away from myspace
can you talk to me about like this cast
number one you guys look like you're
having the best time like you're like
you're having the time in your lives uh
what was it like
doing i mean essentially working with
them hanging with them dancing
behind the scenes all the rest
it's amazing i think we were all just so
grateful to be there and we were so
grateful to be working because we were
in the middle of a pandemic it was you
know such a wild time where the world
was in lockdown and we were there being
able to do all of these wild and
exciting things and go to all these
incredible locations and be part of
something
mcu is so huge and it's so
important so many people so we really
felt the gravity of that every day and
you know wong is so much fun mark is
such a child but jessica gow is such a
legendary writer and presence on set
like with just all of our producers our
directors our crew our stunt teams like
everyone was just so
passionate about the project
and i'm passionate about each other and
you really felt that
you know
i think in the final result
i hope
well it's
amazing i know people love it we're huge
fans over here uh and titania is like
the best more titania please oh yeah i
mean she i i love her i loved playing
her so much i could play her forever
she's such a ridiculous clown
that's awesome thank you so much
you